so one of the ones that I thought would
be interesting for us to talk about is
abortion because I think you and I
actually are evolving in different ways
oddly because you used to be pro-life
and now you're pro-choice
I've been pro-choice my whole life I
still am but I always say I'm for
grudgingly pro-choice and part of it is
because it seems to me that the
Democrats are going so crazy with
pushing how much later the abortion can
be quite literally now we have the
phrase post birth abortions and now you
know you only have to talk to one doctor
and I know and you know often they won't
even admit that a week before a nine
month pregnancy is coming to term that
that's still not a human I mean some
really really radical stuff yeah that
that is really making me challenge my
own beliefs but since you went the other
way on this how did you evolve on this
really just an understanding the role of
government and I take a more libertarian
position on this issue that government
really shouldn't be in that place of
dictating to a woman the choice that
that she should make I think that there
should be some restrictions though you
know for me personally it's I would not
make that choice for myself but I don't
believe that I should be telling anybody
else the kinds of decisions that they
should make for themselves or for their
family and therefore a woman should have
the right to choose and I will stand up
and fight to protect the right to do so
off point for that I think the third
trimester unless a woman's life or
severe health consequences is at risk
then there shouldn't be an abortion at
third trimester does that seem to be the
issue more than anything else that the
two sides just cannot get close on like
to me it seems because it's dealing with
I mean it's dealing with the most
existential questions that there are the
very nature of life and then it starts
getting into obviously religion birth
secularism and a whole bunch of other
things it seems to me the one where I
always say it's like just because you
think one way it doesn't automatically
mean everyone else is evil on the other
side or like that and you really have a
hard time doing this one with abortion I
think that that right there is is the
necessary kind of conversation to have
because it is it is the assumption right
that if you're not
on my side on this than you are evil
right that somehow Republican hate women
and Democrats hate babies right like
exactly when that's really not the case
you know I disagree with Hillary Clinton
on a ton of things but when she came out
and she said abortion should be safe
legal and rare that's something that I
agree with the the deeper question of
the philosophical questions that you're
talking about I think our discussions
that we need to have but ultimately in
my view the government should not be the
one dictating which side of this whether
you're you know you're saying that
you're taking away a woman's right to
choose or you are mandating that they
take another they actually have an
abortion I don't think that that's a
role government should play and so what
would you say to the people that would
say well wait a minute the government's
supposed to protect life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness what about the life
of the fetus you're just that you're
just having that superseded you're
having the woman's rights to sue person
did a woman is a woman is the one who's
got to live with whatever decision that
she makes and that's where I draw the
line and say that the government should
not be in the position of telling that
woman what choice she must make if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell